amy is Weathers amy is in North Carolina
hi Amy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave it's a pleasure to get to talk
to you
you too what's up I've been listening to
listening to you for quite a while and
I've heard you say before that the whole
life insurance policies are terrible
ways to invest money yes ma'am and my
husband and I each have one and we had
some debt and we decided we went ahead
and decided to go ahead and cash those
out the total between those toons about
26,000 in cash out value so what would
be your advice on how to use that money
going forward wherever you are on the
baby steps well we're back to baby step
one and I had some medical expenses last
year and we had to use all of our
emergency fund for that and and we had
about seventeen thousand five hundred
dollars in debt medical and right now
we've got that paid down to about a
thousand is that what's the 17,500
medical debt and the other debt is the
car and we have about 11,000 on our car
sure your medical problems you know she
go borrow on a car no it didn't we've
done some things out of order and I'm
trying to get straightened out or you
just stop doing it and went back to
living normal and now you're starting
exactly okay so the danger of using this
to pay off everything is is that you do
that cycle again because next time next
time you go buy a stupid car on stupid
debt you're not gonna have a whole life
policy to bail your stoop itself out
exactly this is how I talk to myself too
all right yeah so I mean really the two
of you have to pinky swear in spit shake
no no no recycling this crap again okay
okay now do you guys have term life
insurance in place we do you have term
life insurance in place and I realized
after listening to you son that that's
really all we needed the term life
insurance yeah if you've got enough of
that then yes I would cash the whole
life out
I would pay off the seventeen thousand
five hundred including the eleven
thousand dollar car and I would begin to
replenish my emergency fund and put you
back into baby step three am i right
right and I was told that we're going to
have a taxable gain off of at a like
nineteen hundred dollars or more it's
very unusual they gave you the exact
numbers on mine I don't know what my
husband is but mine it was going to be
nineteen hundred Jane you must have had
these things I never we had them for
seventeen years
okay because it's very unusual for them
to even make any money and the fact that
it made two thousand dollars is shocking
okay so you have taxes on two thousand
dollars it's gonna cost you five hundred
bucks in taxes okay okay and so it's
it's ordinary income your basis is the
total of all your premiums paid in and
my cash value minus the total of all
your premiums paid in is usually a loss
in your case it sounds like it made
nineteen hundred dollars and so your tax
rate apply to that so set aside four
hundred bucks for some extra taxes this
year if you've got a tax refund last
year you wouldn't even have to worry
about that you just get less of a refund
which you need to adjust that anyway so
yes I would cash that in but the most
important part of this story is that
when life happens the next time you're
not going to be in debt and you're gonna
have an emergency fund and you're not
gonna go into debt ever again you have
to seal that you have to pinky swear and
spit shake because it's gonna if you
cycle this it gets harder and harder
and harder to do it